millions of dollars are coming to nevada
to help in the fight against the opioid
epidemic now the funds are from a
settlement with a major drug maker joe
mohler joining us now live from the
strip with how some recovery experts
would like to see this money spent joe
yeah one opioid addiction recovery
expert says the settlement is a long
time coming and this money can really
help people recover and save thousands
of lives here in southern nevada
i had no idea the devastation that my
life would become garrett hayden says he
was prescribed opioids for pain after a
crash years ago and has been in recovery
for seven years you know what that one
prescription of vicodin started when i
was 17 years old turned into a 10-year
opiate battle thousands of similar
stories are out there lawsuits were
recently filed against drug distributors
and drug maker johnson and johnson for
their role in the ongoing epidemic a 26
billion dollar settlement was reached
this week it was announced nevada will
get roughly 285 million dollars to take
on the epidemic over the next two
decades companies knew exactly what they
were doing
in the marketing of these products
distribution of these products and
manufacturing of these products recovery
expert sean o'donnell from foundation
for recovery says the money can help in
a number of ways however the state has
not announced exactly how it will be
distributed so i'm really hoping that
some of the funding will go towards
establishing some good treatment options
some good recovery supports and harm
reduction measures according to the
health district all overdose deaths were
up from 418 in 2019 to 560 in 2020
primarily driven by fentanyl start
investing in housing employment supports
um peer recovery support services
now back out here live
also says he hopes that some of this
money goes towards recovery efforts in
rural nevada because he says it is
lacking in a lot of areas outside of the
metropolitan regions reporting live this
evening on this trip joe muller live
local now